hearty my friend
congratulations songwriter of the year
how does it feel to hold that thing
it's heavy
um no it's it's awesome it means
everything uh
yeah i
don't think i've fully
processed the whole situation but um
it's incredible to know that
everybody that was nominated are like
veterans and i know that i'm
young and i'm i'm up and coming but uh
i don't know to to feel
to know that that
a big group of people think that i
deserve this is uh incredible and very
just amazing when do you think it'll hit
you when you're placing it on the shelf
at home and you're like wait what i have
no idea
um
i'm weird like that though like i don't
know i i i i don't process things
i have no idea but it hit me pretty hard
um
this afternoon when i found out
this is
i just i care so much about the
songwriting industry and and
everything involved the grind the young
ones the the ogs and and um
i'm more passionate about that than i
think anything in the music industry and
so this one um
it's it's definitely
it's going to be easier to process
because i definitely care so much about
it if that makes sense it's it's
really important to me do you know where
it will go in your home
um
i mean i don't know i hope
i don't have like a lot of trophies but
maybe we'll find some sort of trophy
case
situation and this will be the first one
so we'll see you have a lot more coming
in your future my friend you've got this
trophy plus a wedding ring you're gonna
gain pretty soon too i mean it's not too
shabby to be you right now no it's not
it's been a really great year
and it's going to continue to be great
um
yeah i have a lot to look forward to and
a lot to be thankful for and one of your
best friends morgan wallen also won big
tonight album of the year what does this
moment mean for him too dude we
me and my fiance cried i think more
over that award than than this one
it means a lot
for him
it means a lot he
he works very hard he deserves that
award
and
for those that don't know
you know your peers our co-workers vote
for who should win this award um and to
know that
the entire country music industry
voted for him to win that everybody
deserves a second chance deserves a
chance to fight for themselves and and
that's exactly what's happened and so
this was bigger than
that award for him it meant a lot and
i'm very proud of him